hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic
now wait for me to type oh that's right
well it finally happened I can promise
by the movie I just saw a film so bad
you know what to do the actual point is
much funnier yeah I know the problem hey
why did I install that again
ground my lines right every star is
boring this is so boring and yeah
obviously uterus like it okay I don't
normally say okay
Oh ring this is the box you really don't
say Oh B Oh doesn't match my life I
don't bow no boring this is a boring
this is a boring give the show ah this
is a boring this is a bore Rinka to the
show oh you got a dog you guys it was a
little pitchy dog look around were you
right on you were there you were
believing it you were loving it
Pola how do you vote oh you're such a
sweetheart you tried so hard oh my god
you're the most do you think oh that we
got on Hell's Kitchen
you stupid okay I thought it was the
most putrid nonsense I've ever heard
vomited onto a microphone you should be
deeply ashamed in fact your parents
should be ashamed for even blight in the
world with your miracle we shoot down
our American Idols if only we have one
black guy we could have done like a
record Idol sketch bar go red he looks
like you lost another way they're Indian
now yeah dog got a stomach stapling dog
so I guess 22 years before that
onslaught of rambling text there was a
sweet innocent old nun who ran a lovely
little orphanage where she sold her
children to the most
horrible science experiments wait what
yeah I'm with him
what's that I was doing like a little
fairy tale I was a heading chanted to do
like you did before doc my money also
says I should my money also says that
you'd pick an accent that's my bed
rockin my mummy also says I should pick
an accent before I did my money my money
I just don't know no you're scaring me
this is Edward our main character who
makes his living as a professional model
of exhibit in it the performer fastball
model of so long rare rough that's her
so long rare white trigger I'm sorry so
long rare white hard line do it again
and do it right you stupid cow it would
better you monkey
hey any say your way oh this enjoy
yourself unless of course that man was
Chuck Norris line unless of course that
man was like and as we all know any
woman who has glasses he did and as we
all know any woman who has glasses in
Caesar as if wearing glasses makes you
look any smarter I need glasses good as
if wearing glasses makes you look any
smarter good Hey oh yeah I mean I like
am i I should I should get some
definitely it'd be like the Clark Kent
thing it'd be totally different person
cuz I feel like you got yes if wearing
glasses makes you look any smarter yeah
I mean they're very attractive I mean I
should get some I think they look great
I mean
the wonders for you really brings up and
color of your eyes and then yeah I'm
sure your vision is perfect as if
wearing glasses actually makes you
intelligent please
no I mean that they work wonders for you
I mean that makes you look very very
sharp very intelligent it really brings
out your eyes I mean you're very
handsome man I do him if I was that way
I'm not I mean I like chicks I'm all
about the pussy and then like Aileen
said Rock she was such a bitch to me at
the mall oh my god no I was walking past
the gap and I was like hey Lane what's
up and then she just went what of
plunges right yes who wears Crocs
outside and that's difficult and it
annoyed like hell out of me I think I
think it makes her look so smart but
they don't they just know she's up so we
see Slater trying to walk away from the
plot when he said when he had two
different rule oh so we see Slater
trying to walk away from the plot when
he has a sudden suspension suspicious
that is so he's suspension of disbelief
Emma head over there I had a sudden
suspension one time I don't get a pin on
me oh no my acting is going Shatner
spark ah must reach warp console I
wasn't having no voice I'll have to say
a thing we've all said word we loves him
so much
no we hate Edward we hate him with all
our I'm only good at 25 piece sets I
think I've decided actually Spoony makes
a better woman thanks
I think valley girl my god I don't think
you're doing your heart on an animal
like I think Spoony has the voice like
the nose Mooney has the pitch but you
have the inflections oh my god I just
assaulted
yeah how very democratic you two are so
clicky I mean like God HOD what about
the business club okay sorry mmm-hmm
what about the business of that little
girl why I mean what kind of woman acts
like this just breaks into your home and
starts making out with you granted I
wish more women acted like that but this
is really pushing it hey your mom acts
like that my mother was a sage
cha-cha-cha thank you off camera guy
hike ah
I'll bravely abandon use you can fend
for yourself look I was looking at your
balls oh so like really what how many
people are gonna thank you and to see
some of these shots that were like
standing up that's what that's what I'm
holding the laptop while I'm typing my
god that is dr. Briggs taller than the
mall I'm telling her how are you holding
on telephone don't ask so they're
approached by more people with
compromised nervous systems but their
bullets hurt them now because luckily
his friend gave a bunch of civilians
some automatic weapons I buck the point
and if you make it down here while
you're dead you'll become alive that was
spoonie's line I know I know okay
fuck you all I wasn't feeling I'm sorry
bitch I'll be my trailer and if you make
it down here while you're dead then
you'll become alive but if you're half
that in half alive then you might have a
better chance of coming down with this
thing but if when you're a Samba in the
cage zombie but all joking or using only
your bunny dead but if you're a real
Johnny you want it I got it really right
after and then like lavitus effector
kind of power like a black lantern and
made it with another magic power I
should be doing that one cuz I'm the
comic-book guy well you know more about
it obvious obviously an orally charged
thing operated launched a Malaysian
planets bottle gets out Givens let me
got launch down all the cave were you're
kind of in the semi shadow stayed Arab
life and it's a row ground girliness but
hiragana you make sure it an extra great
onyx you've got your missing like contra
because dr. Moreau helicoptering had to
go back to the planet Vulcan and then
sherek has to put it what I started
laughing he wait a minute she looked at
her head up and play that again
how Oh
what is with that how do you get away
with that
I guess Stephen Dorff was right she
really would be okay nobody associated
with this movie is okay huh and I would
have got the way with it too if it
hadn't been for you pesky kids rah troll
booth no is this so that was uber balls
alone in the dark how does it fare out
God oh sorry I on the first line yeah
boy this one's really brings us to hate
each other you and me I've done
professionally man I love you both still
okay I don't like you tap BloodRayne to
wise guy it's for you know that's it
critic okey-dokey
okay there we go
this shit when I get I'm sorry nothing's
working
I mean it's got hot chicks
blood rain - what's that oh five damages
every I botch it up tear my fingers
blood rain - hi well you gotta be mean I
got there it's over now leave okay
remember of my revolution of the mask
what about in the name of the king of
Dungeon Siege tale but I thought you
went for my forehead yeah that's okay
come on give me your list this is gonna
take all night
all right I got blood brain I thought
you was gonna interrupt no no we're
going to love me too
I gotta be so mean we can watch seed Hey
oh no that was my okay okay we're
getting closer now
okay we're getting closer there is over
now quick one net dude I totally didn't
hit me dude what you see is what you got
Pizza Delivery hard science delivery bro
hello I'm the stripper you ordered am I
not in this sketch Kurt this is my only
line yeah it's a goofy image assets